I'm concerned about the effect this
subject will have upon my daughter
instead let's arrange for her to marry
you in a few years Elizabeth I want you
to accompany the boy take care of him
you know play doctor and stuff also
Dustin Hoffman was apparently
unavailable to play the old man with a
long dark wig and a red coat and a white
scarf we find out later that the
medallion calls to the dead pirates on
the Black Pearl so why are they just
sailing in the fog like a myth right now
nobody on board except Elizabeth sees
the ship that is literally like a
hundred yards away and clearly visible
Jack steps off the boat with his right
leg but his left leg hits the dock first
[Music]
this is some truly terrible formation
right here these lines aren't even
remotely straight what have they never
practiced these before have they not
seen the opening to a few good men
Elizabeth is about to faint from the
corset but decides to stand right on the
edge of the fort wall first the governor
wants to shoot Jack on sight without
knowing who he is or what he's done
then when he finds out Jack is a pirate
he wants to hang him why the chain hang
him to delay Jack's death so he can
escape later yeah that seems like
protocol just handcuffed a guy and leave
him unattended next to the rich girls
scene does not contain a lapdance
soldiers approached Jack from the front
even though all of them are behind him
will you make up your fucking mind we
didn't shoot him before because you said
hang him remember this guy's closing his
eyes while firing this guy's got his
head turned completely to the side and
this guy appears to be three feet tall
one take cover from what the single guy
in chains running away from all the
soldiers but I thought the order was to
shoot him now we'll turn his facial hair
grows from this to this in a few hours
let go cause to us except when it's in a
drawer or right next to them in the
beginning of the movie Khal Drogo would
totally have kicked leg Alyssa's ass had
it not been for this fortunate sign
falling incident why would the Pirates
care if she dropped it can they not just
jump right in after it and grab it I
mean the ship's still in the harbor
right Will Turner is a dick to maps why
they haven't heard anything else if
you're gonna do this you might as well
not even try to hide this is way more
suspicious than if you were just out the
open walking around will and Jack must
have the strength of a hundred men to
pull a boat down completely underwater
with a pocket of air how did their
clothes dry so fast the British dude
seriously left not one single guy on
this ship
not one dude is it naval policy to
abandon ship completely when you search
other ships for two fucking criminals
this guy had no chance and he knew it
before he swung I think he was just
tired of working and wanted to take a
dip this tiny boat explodes from the
impact of the Dauntless well before the
Dauntless ever actually touches it it's
got to be the best part I've ever seen
inferior officer rubs it in the face of
his superior also the Black Pearl came
to town and destroyed all kinds of but
left two of the best ships in the fleet
completely alone
big billows the Pirates kidnapped girls
so often they have this whole skeletons
running the ship routine thing that's
all choreographed and everything these
mostly drunk pirate losers have better
alignment and timing than the fucking
British soldiers do where is all this
light coming from if not the moon and if
it's moonlight why aren't they showing
their true skeleton nature he's not even
the one driving are we really supposed
to believe Jack Sparrow saw this cannon
being fired 20 feet away and the
Cannonball coming right at him but still
had time to duck we'll somehow not only
survives the ship explosion but then
also manages to swim over a hundred
yards in a matter of seconds despite not
knowing how Jack escaped the last time
Barbosa figures putting Jack on the same
island will do the trick this time so
when did they fix the door to this
prison cell because this is the same
cell they put Jack in and then during
the attack it was damaged never sat well
with big jack what we did to Jack
Sparrow the two bumbling idiot pirates
are reduced to being exposition vessels
people and ghosts are really good at
walking underwater in this movie
Jack shoots Barbosa before the coins and
Will's blood go into the treasure chest
meaning Barbosa shouldn't have any flesh
that a bullet could do any damage - if
this is supposed to all the sudden kill
Barbosa shouldn't Jack have a gaping
wound from being stabbed with a sword
before shouldn't all the dead pirates
have wounds that magically show up that
they didn't notice because they were all
dead already
this putting the eye back in thing was
cute and funny when he was dead but now
that he's alive again how is he able to
put it back in and control it bumbling
idiot pair number one meet bumbling
idiot pair number two this cowboy and
credit scene no one stays four because
no one expects an end credits scene for
a movie based on a theme park ride also
the stove lid on this chest is clearly
closed in this shot but somehow
magically open for the monkey to reach
in and steal some gold in the next shot
that's not good enough not sure
Tortuga will never fight Oh wretched
hive of scum and villainy
[Music]